es war eine der sensation des jahres
2017 das interstellare objekt um humor
durchquerte unser sonnensystem jetzt
wurde ein weiterer besucher von
außerhalb des sonnensystems entdeckt zum
science fiction gibt sie jeden tag
spannende science videos abonnenten
kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasste nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen als man vor zwei jahren um
uhr entdeckte war die wissenschaft in
heller aufruhr handelte sich bei dem
objekt um einen asteroiden einen kometen
oder sogar eine ähnlichen sonne
fest steht jedenfalls dass humor aus
einem fremden lichtjahre entfernten
stern system stammt und sich irgendwie
in unser sonnensystem bewegt hat sogar
der angesehene leiter der abteilung
astronomie der harvard university
professor aber im loeb erklärte dass es
möglich sei dass es sich hier um ein
außerirdisches raumschiff oder teile
davon handelt werden ja hier auf tricks
um im exklusiv-interview umso
aufregender ist die entdeckung die einem
russischen amateurastronomen jetzt
gelang mit seinem selbstgebauten 65 cm
teleskop entdeckte er ein weiteres
objekt von außerhalb des sonnensystems
noch ein horror das objekt trägt deshalb
seinen namen borisov wie marmor konnten
forschende feststellen dass sich
borissov auf einer sogenannten über
bullischen bahn bewegt also von
außerhalb in unser sonnensystem herr
eingerastet ist und es auch bald wieder
verlassen wird untersuchungen zeigen
dass borissov einen hohen eisenanteil
hat es sich also um einen kometen
handelt im dezember wird er der sonne am
nächsten kommen und dann wohl durch
deren hitze teilweise schmelzen der erde
könnte sich wohl nur auf bis zu 300
millionen kilometer nähern so dass eine
eingehende untersuchung nicht möglich
sein wird die entdeckung von ubisoft
zeigt dass immer nur kein einmaliges es
war scheinbar bewegen sich öfter
extrasolare objekte sich unser
sonnensystem in alten daten wohl ja
bereits ein weiteres interstellare soc
entdeckt borissov wäre damit bereits
nummer drei in zukunft könnte dieses
wissen uns dabei helfen anhand solcher
eindringen informationen über fremde
sternsysteme und deren planeten zu
erhalten
die entdeckung von drei extrasolaren und
decken innerhalb von nur zwei jahren
könnte bedeuten dass solche objekte
einfach viel viel häufiger sind als
ursprünglich angenommen
das könnte bedeuten dass diese häufung
eine nicht natürliche ursache hat denn
obwohl es sich bei borissov sehr
wahrscheinlich um einen kometen handelt
ist natürlich nicht auszuschließen dass
er wieder eine außerirdische sonde ist
denn wer weiß schon welche technologie
außerirdische zivilisation zur erkundung
des weltraums einsetzen und warum hat
man früher keine solchen objekte
entdeckt wenn sie scheinbar so häufig
durch unser sonnensystem fliegen die
ganzen thematik der interstellaren
objekt dem bleibt super spannend aber
auch super rätselhaft mehr zum thema
borisov noch ein humor anklicken
anschauen und unbedingt unbedingt astor
comics tv abonnieren am kanal bis dann
bleibt dran